hey it's another week and it's another  free piece of downloadable content for  the already content-rich Witcher 3 Wild  Hunt this week another side quest  beckons for your attention if you're  around level 24 then head on over to the  small marshy town of Orton you'll find a  notice board with a contract that kicks  off a short but cool quest with a decent  reward without getting into spoiler  territory it's a quest that has nice  nods to the story the lesser evil found  in the last wish book by Andrzej  Sapkowski and it alludes to events that  happen to Goro right before the first  game it's kind of small bit of  fanservice so check it out if you're  curious it's short but soon  you